well this is the season for cleaning
purging and getting organized joining me
this morning is professional organizer
JC patino of the neat method thanks for
being here thanks for having me we've
been chatting a lot about the ways that
you get organized you clean edit Purge
all of that and you've got some great
tips on getting us organized cleaned out
in the kitchen it can be overwhelming
I'm not going to lie yes and you were
saying to start in the kitchen we all
have those drawers you know that hold
everything yes what do you call them I
call them a junk drawer we call them
command centers command centers okay
they hold everything in your house that
does something yes and
and yeah and so that's the main um
people spend an average of six months of
their life looking for lost items six
months of their life okay so if we can
get organized we can actually get time
back which everyone's always looking for
ways to save time it saves you time and
it saves you money too yes because I've
lost I've left checks that were uncached
you know refunds rebates all of that uh
let's start in the kitchen can we do
that because you've got a Nifty little
organizer there because you say all of
us have too many utensils in the kitchen
drawer right yes so where should we
start how should we start by editing out
those unused items or if you have a
multitude of items so if you have
10 Pizza Cutters or 20 spoons if you
have 20 spoons yes stick with your
favorites and you can toss the okay
disposables disposables or you say um
you say donate you can donate them yes
okay and then this is a neat little you
can buy these on Amazon Walmart
Container Store and this is just
implemented into any drawer oh so it's
expandable and yep and then it's a
divided and immediately up levels
so you could put as many or as few in a
drawer as you wanted right depending on
they're very Universal you can use them
in closets or the kitchen Command Center
drawers anywhere what are some of the
other steps okay so you have to edit
before you organize yes so decluttering
and organize are two separate things
okay which a lot of people get excited
and they're like I want to I'm going to
clean the whole house I'm gonna organize
the whole house first we have to
declutter before we can organize and and
so what's your what's the mindset to get
rid of what you really don't need
because a lot of people like me I Hold
On To Everything thinking I'm going to
use it again and so an easy way to take
kind of the emotion out of it is if you
have a thing of items you're like maybe
I'm going to need this put it in a bin
put it in a container put at the top of
your closet or in the garage where you
can't see it and if in three months you
haven't touched it if I don't go looking
for it I don't need it is that right
okay so after you declutter then what do
you do take it immediately take it to
donations so your donation bag you are
taken right away don't let us sit in
your house
and don't let us in the trunk of your
car for months take it right away so
it's out and immediately your home
you've left approved all right so we've
we've decluttered next coming up in the
next half hour we're going to organize
and you're going to show us some easy
methods for organizing clothes maybe
toys in your kids room yep we're going
to do that coming up with JC coming up
in just a few minutes so stay with us
I'm so excited this is going to get me
excited to organize again oh forget I
have to declutter first that's the
hardest part we'll be right back
everybody stay with us good